one of the biggest factors of having
faith is to control your imagination
anybody i know that typically has a lot
of anxiety or panic they have a very
strong imagination but they can't
control okay and it's let loose
and this imagination goes to places that
could be dark scary whatever it is yeah
you see shadows everywhere you see
shadows everywhere yeah you know you
know i got four kids one has a lot of
nightmares one doesn't have any
nightmares the one that has a lot of
nightmares the most creative mind
imagination and the other one's like now
i got to get the job done it's a very
interesting uh mindset on how this thing
works but once you get a hold of your
imagination
and you can have some sort of a faith
that the future looks bright
people want to be around that and that
gives you some peace of mind knowing no
matter what everything's going to be un
under control i'm going to do whatever i
can do but whatever i can to do i got to
have faith to see there's nothing i can
do about it